the only way i found with the mushroom
is
first of all to rave a lot while you're
stoned than to have a tape recording
going and then to play it back and then
when you hear it you say oh yes when i
was saying that i was thinking this this
and this
but retention of it like i say the whole
thing is retention a person who could
retain
a single 20-minute burst of psilocybin
hallucinations would just have cornered
the graphic arts market for the rest of
the century
and
why is that and how could it be possible
we work so hard to produce outlandish
images
and yet we fall so far short
everything moves very slowly because
there is so much momentum you know i
can't remember what futurist said it but
one of them said you know 90
of the future is already existent in the
present
you know these 1984 automobiles many of
them will be around in 10 years any
picture of a city street 10 years from
now must include those automobiles and
us most of us will be around we're the
main thing holding back the future
that's why i'm so baffled by people like
robert anton wilson who are so concerned
to live forever i mean do you want to be
around in 500 years a gaping neanderthal
who spends their time in city parks
looking out at what's going on
[Laughter]
no i think it's just better to move off
the plane and make way for other people
anyway i'm at death
i won't say death doesn't frighten me
but i i certainly i think i have a place
for it in my cosmology i'm pretty
excited by it i never thought i would
come to the position
that
that the mind could survive physical
death but more and more i think that's
probably true it's amazing how little is
known about the mind i mean consider see
psychology is entirely a kind of a scam
at the close of the 19th century when
feeling the bumps on people's heads
got ruled out they got sent out of the
tent
and astrology got sent out of the tent
those guys were no longer allowed and a
cultist they got sent out of the tent
but freud was a pretty shrewd cookie and
he got his medical degree before he
embarked on this stuff and he managed to
get them under the tent
so they're scientists
you know but my god they're science it's
just a shot in the dark no matter what
form of psychotherapy you practice
one-third get better one-third get worse
one-third stay the same
so
you know
and and the most sciences are expected
to define under what conditions they
would abandon their premises
you know and we've never been able to
get marxists or freudians to belly up to
the bar and actually tell us under what
conditions would you agree to say you're
wrong
and so it's not a science at all it's a
kind of a pseudoscience being practiced
as a science we are not even in a
position to say that the brain
has very much of a relationship to
thought
all these uh
electroencephalographic
studies are very very crude i mean they
they say well a certain form of
awareness has a certain electrical
signature but going from that to saying
that the brain generates the mind
we can't be sure you know i mean i
always ask is is is the mind the piano
or is it horowitz and if the mind is
horowitz what are we going to learn
about the mind by tearing up the piano
or is it the music or is it the music
and uh well the mind is all of those
it's not it's not located it's not
located and what and in what
relationship it stands to the brain is
very hard to say and in what
relationship it stands to the individual
is very hard i think the brain is there
for when the mind has grunt work to do
yes well the i think it's like a piano
the mind leans over and plays the keys
and
and then something happens
but
i think psychology needs to return to a
pure
baconian method and by that i mean let's
go back and collect facts as many facts
as we can
millions of them and wait for an idea to
come along about what all these facts
mean but the current situation in
psychology is apparently that anything
goes i mean freudians believe one thing
reiki and something diametrically
opposed all these humanistic and
transpersonal and human potential things
some people say it's musculature other
people say it's birth trauma other
people say it's genetics other people
say it's linguistic cueing and
nobody can present a proof of their
position sufficient to quiet these other
points of view so that means it's not
it's in a pre-paradigm phase
and we're it's much too early for them
to have been allowed
in inside the big tent of science
of course this is frustrating we like to
think we're an advanced society and
certainly
thinking is the most advanced phenomenon
in the universe open for our inspection
it's too humbling
for us to say well we can't think about
thinking we must wait 100 or 200 years
so many things work that
it seems like we're still in almost the
shamanic stage or not even in the
shamanic stage since actually i think in
terms of cure rate and that sort of
thing folk psychiatry is probably way
out in front of what urban
psychoanalysts are able to deliver as a
cure rate there may be many factors
impinging on that certainly pre-literate
cultures have very uh
consistent and cohesive consensus that
when someone falls out of that consensus
maybe they can be returned to it more
easily than in a pluralistic society
where you usually don't have your
consensus restored you're usually told
to just become a different person you
know
i mean for instance in in pre-literate
societies if you have a religious crisis
and say you no longer want to believe in
the tribal god you're not offered then a
smorgasbord of religious options you're
told that you will believe in the tribal
god
[Music]
you